[Music]
all right let's go to nancy in
birmingham what's up nancy
hi dr john thanks so much for taking my
call of course what's happening
um
oh i
guess i'll just dive right in
yeah jump in and then i'll uh i'll steer
us where we need to go
okay
i need to go back to therapy okay but i
am absolutely petrified
because my first experience with therapy
was about 20 years ago
and
involved a four-year
sexual relationship with my therapist
okay
um
why does that petrify you in the future
i just
i i have been very very cute
have a history of childhood sexual abuse
okay
and
just
i'm just very very careful okay and
my my bigger issue i also don't trust
women so that makes it even harder why
don't you trust women
um
i have four older sisters
the oldest one is 11 something that
one closest to me is
11 years older than me
and i was
surprised
my
mother and father were
greatest generation parents and
um
were busy doing their own thing and
i kind of was ignored and left my own
devices and
no one paid much attention to the fact
that
i was
there was clearly something wrong you're
struggling how old are you now
um i'm 55. 55.
what what what takes you back to
counseling nowadays
um
my son
was
in
an accident a head-on collision
uh his freshman year of college
and
was a glasgow three severe brain injury
coming in
and
i have been his primary
caregiver um
for all for the last
seven eight years
we just finished our 11th brain surgery
and i've hit burnout i can't even put my
foot on the floor
and i'm also going back to what i know
are negative coping skills
disassociating
cutting um
just
things i had had really managed to quit
okay
you've had a really rough go of it huh
yeah
can i just tell you i'm
sorry thanks
um
i know you know this but it's gonna say
it out loud that shouldn't have happened
to you when you were a kid
nobody should have abused you nobody
should have um
taking advantage of your body
your mom and dad should have seen that
they had a hurting little girl your
sister should have seen they had a
hurting little sister and somebody
should have stepped in on behalf of that
little girl oh i'm sorry i didn't
mention the abuser was my brother-in-law
okay
oh man
makes it even worse right
yeah
i'm sorry
um
i'm also sorry that you went and sat
down with somebody who was a trained
professional
and you said here's how i'm hurting
and they took advantage of you
for four years
and for people listening to this
yes it takes two to ten go yeah stakes
two to have sex with each other and all
that
um
but it's the height of unethical
professional practice for a counselor to
engage in any sort of sexual
relationship with their clients period
because people come in and there's a
very emotional intimacy that happens in
a counseling setting there's a very
intimate setting
and
man you can take advantage of somebody
and that's what was done to you nancy
and so on on behalf of counselors
everywhere i'm sorry that somebody took
advantage of you and treated you that
way they shouldn't have done that
thanks
and that brings us to right this second
okay
oh let me say this i'm also sorry man my
best friend on the planet my oldest best
friend is um
a traumatic brain survivor um
still a paraplegic is never gonna be
able to get up and run around and be
goofy like we used to be
and um
struggles just to do basic life things
and
his mom is a saint and someone who i
love deeply his brother is one of my
oldest um closest friends on the planet
and um i spoke at his dad's funeral very
close to me and i also know what kind of
trauma that ricochets through an entire
family so i'm sorry about your little
boy
okay
you're 55 which means you're a little
more than halfway done
right right
statistically speaking
the question you have to ask yourself is
is this going to be nancy's story
or
are you interested in
changing everything
not undoing what has happened the abuse
will always be there it happened that
the therapist that took advantage of you
will always be there your son's gonna
need care
but i'm talking about looking forward
and writing something new and building
something that hasn't existed before
it sounds like in a pretty dysfunctional
family system
that you can take the back half of your
life
and sleep for the first time in a long
time and laugh for the first time in a
long time and not only put your feet on
the floor but go move around and hike
and go for walks
and get child care and get the job but
you see what i'm saying i'm talking
about building a whole new life
are you interested in that
yes
okay because what what it's going to
take to do that is you choosing to
do the work
and not carry that stuff from the past
anymore the things that were done to you
we have to set the bricks down and start
doing things to our lives moving forward
and that's really heavy lifting are you
in for that because you've been
surviving for
45 years right
i mean
yes
um
i tried going back to therapy uh once
with the female
and
i could just
feel i mean one i made her change chairs
with me so i could sit closest to the
door
and
when i told her what had happened
with the other therapist her first
question was are you sure you didn't
misconstrue what was going on
and i got up and walked down good for
you
good for
you
see you got some strength in there don't
you
yeah yeah
you do yeah i mean i quit my job and i
was
the top producer for the largest
company in our industry yeah no you're
you're
an old tough gangster nancy
and what you've been doing is using that
strength and that energy to survive
and to defend yourself from threats that
were there in the past that are no
longer
pressing on you
but they're still pressing on you you
get you see what i'm saying
yeah
and
if you take that energy and stop
fighting old demons
they don't have any gas left in them
and use that energy to start building
something now you're talking about total
life transformation
and by the way
i saw my mom do it in her 50s and 60s
and now she's into her 70s
she just called yesterday and said she's
going to uh
spend next summer as a professor at
oxford and like she's just living this
crazy second half of her life
and you can too
if you're all in
yeah but i gotta figure out how to make
that first step you do
no hold on back up there's no figuring
out
one of the things that's important to
know about our feelings is that they are
alarms they're signals they're important
and they lie to us
because our feelings have one job that's
to keep us alive
and so there's no figuring out how to
take the next step you just take the
next step so what does that mean as soon
as we get off this phone call
you call a local counselor in your area
and there's a bunch of good ones in
birmingham
and you
don't lose sleep over a female counselor
call a male counselor
and tell them
20 years ago i went and saw a male
counselor and they
um
took advantage of me sexually
that cannot happen again and if they're
a good counselor they'll say thank you
so much for sharing that i'm grateful
for you that will not happen here in my
office this is a safe place
and then you're gonna have to make a
choice because your body's gonna start
sending the alarms off we're getting
close we're getting close and you're
gonna have to say no i'm gonna sit
through this one i'm gonna push through
the other side of this healing
are you into that
yes i just oh so now i'm really
hyperventilated
exactly exactly
here's a way to diffuse the hyper
vigilance call it out
even if you have to write down on a
piece of paper
i was sexually abused by
a therapist i'm very hyper vigilant i've
got sexual abuse in my past
i got a kid with a traumatic brain
injury that i'm a primary caretaker for
and i'm 55 and i'm freaking exhausted
and i want to live a life of joy with
the time i got left
write that down
and take that on a piece of paper and
read it to the therapist that would be a
gift to any therapist
it'd be a gift because you're i'm taking
the air out of the hyper vigilance
hypervigilance works in the shadows
right it it lurks behind the facts and
behind the data and behind our lives and
just keeps us revved up for a fight
that's probably never gonna come
right so i'm just gonna turn all the
lights on i'm gonna i'm gonna turn the
lights on yep i'm super hyper vigilant
right now
it kind of takes the it's it's like if a
bunch of navy seals were coming into
your house and you flipped all the
lights and you're like i see all the
seals i'm not fighting you and you can
just arrest me in fact i handcuffed
myself
right
it's it's kind of like uh
okay right i'm just gonna take all the
hypervigilance away i'm just gonna make
the move i'm gonna go for it
so there's no figuring out the next step
it's just making the call and going
and then for you it's going to be
important is to go the second time and
to go the third time and go the fourth
time
hear me very clearly nancy there is no
path forward that's going to be
comfortable
because your body's going to fight you
every step of the way as you head on
into this new path because it wants to
keep you safe
and right now what used to keep you safe
is now keeping you under water and your
body is saying we're out
we're checking out
so these feelings this hyper vigilance
this alertness that's been
running the show for so long
has pushed your body to a breaking point
and it's time for the thinking part of
your brain the rational part the fact
part the wait a minute i'm freaking
nancy and i'm a baller i am getting back
in the driver's seat thank you for
driving for the last 45 years feelings
and thoughts i'm grateful for you and
hyper vigilance you kept me alive good
call
now i'm gonna have some joy in my life
and i'm gonna heal i'm gonna quit
carrying around this stuff from 20 years
ago and 30 years ago 40 years ago
i'm going to do something different
expect discomfort expect it
kind of like opening the oven and
sticking your hand in it's warm it's hot
and you gotta be very careful but you
pull out a plate of cookies man so good
you gotta deal with the heat to get
those out or you gotta put your hand in
that freezing cold freezer to get the
ice cream out
it's just part of it it's good stuff
hang on the line i'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
uh my latest book i want you to read it
cover to cover and i want you to take it
with you to therapy take it with you to
your counselor and say hey i've read
this book and i want to take ownership
of some of these things i'm going to
start slowly shifting my thoughts and
actions and let's go make this thing
happen
i can't tell you how proud of you i am
nancy i'm so proud of you 55 enough is
enough
and if you're listening you can be 65
you can be 25 you can be 36 you can be
any age
the day you say enough's enough's enough
is the day that everything can be
different
nancy keep us in keep us
keep us notified let us know how this
thing's going can't wait to hear how
your story unfolds